reasons political and industrial and
cultural one example that people could
find if they google it is a guy named
Russell Targ was paid a ton of money by
the CIA to look into this topic of
remote viewing / astral projection
depending on the system cool and he beat
the silver market and got profiled in
the Wall Street Journal for accurately
predicting the silver market we had all
these things that it could be for
personal gain it had to be for the
benefit of the world but he was able to
do something in a way that a major
mainstream publication said yes this is
legit so the question isn't what science
is that there are today that you can
find and walk into a lab and say you
know show me how you can levitate this
cat or show me what she is and prove it
as true or false so that the whole James
Randi thing which I don't wanna get into
it seems to be the slow tounament into
as much objectivity within the
subjective realm as possible these
hypotheses being tested over time of the
fourth dimension of Ashe projection it's
less but more the adoption so if you
take the matrix red pill blue pill and
you look at the matrix